ist das die Karte der Hoffnung eine
Karte der Abschreckung oder eine Karte
der
Herzlosigkeit hier ganz im Südosten
Thüringens in Greiz ist die Bezahlkarte
statt Bargeld für Flüchtlinge schon da
noch als Modellprojekt ab Ende Februar
für alle 740 Asylsuchenden im Kreis
verpflichtend eine landrettin prescht
vor weil ihr Bund und Länder zu langsam
sind ich denke mal wenn man gute
Gedanken hat und das Gut vorschlagen
kann umsetzen kann dann sollte man es
auch tun und nicht darauf warten dass es
andere machen die Bezahlkarte eines
jener Projekte die die
migrationspolitische Wende bringen
sollen Anfang November hatten tief in
der Nacht Kanzler und
Ministerpräsidenten die Latte ziemlich
hochgelegt Karte statt Bargeld striktere
Grenzkontrollen konsequentere
Abschiebungen ich will nicht zu große
Worte ergreifen aber doch sagen dass ich
glaube dass das hier ein sehr
historischer Moment ist in dem wir hier
sitzen aber die Zahlen und damit die
Herausforderungen werden bisher nicht
weniger fast 325 000 neue Asylgesuche
gab es im letzten Jahr 72 000 mehr als
22 für die Beobachter ist der
postulierte historische Moment noch weit
weg der Paradigmenwechsel den die
Koalition im Koalitionsvertrag 221
versprochen hat und den
die Ministerpräsidenten im nur letzten
Jahr gefordert haben von dem sind wir
noch weit entfernt es ist ein enormes
eine enorme Herausforderung irreguläre
Migration zu reduzieren und reguläre zu
stärken die wir ja auch brauchen ich
warne davor zu glauben dass es schnelle
Lösung gibt doch das scheint das Problem
schnelle Lösungen die ins Schaufenster
gestellt und doch kaum realisiert werden
so hatte der Bundeskanzler im Herbst
schnellere Abschiebungen gefordert doch
von den
48200 geplanten Rückführungen wurden
2023 real nur
16430 durchgeführt alles
vorhersehbar also eine große Wachstum
bei den Abschiebungen zu versprechen ist
nicht realistisch das wissen die
deutschen weil sie ja ebenensfalls nach
Österreich Frankreich Spanien Italien
blicken können da gelingen da diese
großen Zahlen von Abschiebungen ja auch
nicht oder die Debatte über sichere
Drittstaaten außerhalb der EU in denen
die europäischen Asylanträge entschieden
werden damit tatsächlich nur die
einreisen die wirklich Schutz brauchen
die Innenministerin prüft das seit
November ich hoffe sehr dass ein solches
Modell ernsthaft geprüft wird was ist
die Alternative das Jahr für
Jahrhunderte tausende Menschen im
Mittelmehr ertrinken und wir die Augen
davor verschließen ich sehe das sehr
skeptisch unter anderem deswegen weil
soweit ich das erkennen kann ein solches
Vorhaben gegen geltendes Recht der
Europäischen Union verstoßen würde es
scheint das Grundproblem der Migration
Politik die unterschiedlichen Haltungen
außerhalb und innerhalb der Ampel
Prüfaufträge die im Nirvana Enden
scheinen wenig hilfreich und während die
spdchefin grundsätzliche Probleme mit
der Bezahlkarte oder den Drittstaaten zu
Protokoll gibt wirken die Appelle aus
der eigenen Koalition schon fast
verzweifelt wir sollten nicht in den
Raum stellen dass das von heute auf
morgen geht wie das von der Opposition
teilweise formuliert wird das braucht
eine sehr sehr gute vorbereit und da
muss man sich auch die Zeit nehmen um
das so zu prüfen dass es dann auch
funktioniert in Greiz machen Sie noch
eine spannende Erfahrung der Verzicht
auf Bargeld schafft nicht nur Sicherheit
vor Diebstählen sondern es kommt auch zu
15 plötzlichen
ausreisen da es ja nun keine
statistischen Erhebungen gibt ob die
Asylsuchenden wegen Geld kommen oder ob
sie wirklich Schutz suchen scheidet sich
hier die SPR vom Weizen keine der
Einzelmaßnahmen wird Migrationsdruck
wohl alleine lösen können ob allerdings
alle zusammen wirken können muss die
Politik jetzt noch
beweisen ja und bei uns nun im Studio
die SPD Vorsitzende Frau Esen guten
Abend guten Abend deren eine ganz
einfache Frage zu Beginn das offizielle
Ziel der bundländerbeschlüsse war ja
irreguläre Migration deutlich
zurückzudrängen können Sie ganz klar
sagen mit einem Wort ja das auch mein
Ziel die Bundesregierung hat ja jetzt
einige gesetzespakete vorgelegt und die
sind auch im Bundestag mittlerweile
beschlossen worden insofern ist da
vieles vorangebracht ähm das große
rückführungspaket aber auch das
staatsangehörigatsgerecht es gehört
alles zusammen auch zu einer
Gesamtkonzeption unserer
Migrationspolitik
die gemeinsame europäische Asyl Politik
wird ja auch vorangebracht da geht es
voran im Trilog und das sind alles
hoffnunggebende Zeichen und trotzdem
muss man ganz klar sagen all diese
Maßnahmen abgesehen von den von der
schleierverhandung an den Grenzen die
eine ziemliche Wirkung auch entfaltet
hat sind die Dinge natürlich nicht
schnell wirksam das ist auch so ja bejah
haben sie es jetzt nicht mit einem Wort
ich frage vor dem Hintergrund dass sie
sich ja gegenüber vielen Maßnahmen die
da beschlossen worden sind beim
bundländertreffen Sie sich vorher
kritisch auch ablehnend geäußert haben
z.B zur Bezahlkarte jetzt haben wir es
konkret im Beitrag gesehen da
funktioniert ein probates Mittel jetzt
aus ihrer Sicht die Bezahlkarte hätte
die Landrätin auch schon lange einführen
können die war ja bisher nicht verboten
nur haben sich die Länder jetzt an den
Bund gewandt er soll doch bitte ordnen
Eingreifen so dass es eine einheitliche
Bezahlkarte in ganz Deutschland gibt der
Bund hat sich in diese Verantwortung
begeben obwohl es nicht sein Thema ist
das muss man auch mal sagen aber das
kommt jetzt voran geht jetzt voran und
wenn das dann dort eingesetzt wird wo
man das wo das gewünscht ist wo man das
möchte dann wird es wohl auch Wirkung
zeigen ja genau Deutsche Städtetag und
der städt- und Gemeindebund die wollen
beide eine bundesweit einheitliche
Regelung werden sie das als Ampel
konkret auf den Weg bringen das ist
bereits auf dem Weg die sind bereits in
Verhandlungen darüber wie das
mit aber das es einheitlich wird na ja
der Bund ist mit den Ländern in
Verhandlungen dass es einheitlich werden
soll das ist der Wunsch der Länder und
der Bund wie wie ich gerade schon gesagt
habe begibt sich in diese Verantwortung
ohne sie zu haben und die Bezahlkarte
auch ganz konkret als Mittel dafür wir
im Beitrag gesehen um geldanreize für
Migration einzudämmen ich bin der festen
Überzeugung dass die allermeisten
Menschen die zu uns kommen nicht wegen
geldinreizen kommen sondern auch auf der
Flucht vor eben Vertreibung vor Krieg
vor
Verfolgung diejenigen die hier eine
wirtschaftliche Perspektive suchen die
sind dann am Ende auch nicht in
asylbewerberleistung oder Bürgergeld
sondern die müssten sich eine Arbeit
suchen denn nur die bietet ja eine
wirkliche Perspektive und da haben wir
ja auch einige mittlerweile über das
chancenaufenthaltsrecht aufgenommen die
eigentlich nur eine Duldung gehabt
hätten genau jetzt haben wir allerdings
gesehen in den Beitrag da hat's diesen
Effekt durchaus gehabt kommen wir zum
zweiten Beispiel zum
drittstaatenmodell der
Migrationsforscher Knaus den wir gerade
auch gesehen haben der sagt die wirksam
mit Abstand wir wirksamste Maßnahme wäre
wenn man sie denn umsetzt das sogenannte
drittstaatenmodell jetzt gibt's ein
Prüfauftrag für nency fäer bislang noch
ohne Ergebnis und wenn wir Stefan
weilgrad gehört haben oder auch den
Kanzler dann klingen die so als gingen
die beide ohnehin nicht davon aus dass
das kommt hat denn die Opposition recht
wenn sie sagt sie wollen das gar nicht
also niemand hat bisher diese diese
Asylverfahren in Drittstaaten Regelung
umgesetzt Großbritannien versucht es ja
und läuft auch gegen die eigene äh gegen
eigene Gerichtsbeschlüsse ähm wir würden
auch gegen europäisches Recht verstoßen
möglicherweise aber niemand hat es
bisher umgesetzt deswegen kann Herr
Knaus vielleicht vermuten dass es die
wirksamste Methode wäre aber wissen kann
man es nicht und es ist eben vor allem
sehr fraglich und das wird geprüft sehr
fraglich ob das im Rahmen des
europäischen Rechts überhaupt möglich
ist als Architekt des türkeideals hatte
da natürlich gewisse Expertise
ähm ein Gegenargument äh von ihnen ist
ja oft auch dass das moralisch nicht
okay sei der Status Quo ist allerdings
so dass wir Abkommen im Moment mit
Libyen mit Tunesien haben sicher keine
rechtlich keine Rechtsstaaten wir haben
derzeit tausendfaches sterben auf dem
Mittelmeer Jahr für Jahr ist der Status
Quo denn besser moralisch besser als so
ein drittstaatenmodell in dem Land wo
die Rechtsstaatlichkeit garantiert ist
das wäre die Voraussetzung zunächst mal
ist eben die Frage ob es im Rahmen des
Europarechts überhaupt möglich ist das
wird jetzt gerade geprüft und grundsät
muss man sich schon auch die Frage
stellen oder der Realität stellen dass
die allermeisten geflüchteten auf dieser
Welt nicht in Deutschland und nicht in
europaanden sondern in Nachbarländern
die bei weitem nicht leistungsfähig sind
sie hatten jetzt gerade lyben und andere
Staaten genannt es sind eben auch
Nachbarländer von Ländern in denen Krieg
und Vertreibung herrscht und
dort zu unterstützen und dafür zu sorgen
dass die Menschen dort gut versorgt sind
wäre natürlich durchaus auch eine
Möglichkeit um eben Menschen zu
unterstützen und dennoch
herrscht gibt es bei uns ein Asylrecht
das in der Verfassung festgelegt ist und
wir sind natürlich auch über die Genfer
Flüchtlingskonvention verpflichtet
Menschenschutz zu bieten wenn Sie sich
an uns wenden fren vielen Dank für das
Interview vielen Dank für den Besuch im
Studio sehr gern